I want you all to meet Michael Gardner
and his 10-year-old daughter, Ava.
A few years ago, Michael began his journey
to become a seamster and he thrifted old clothes
to make new outfits for Ava as a way to bond with her
and inspire confidence.
Oh, Michael, you're like literally the dad
we all wish we had.
Michael taught Ava how to sew
when she was just five years old
and they've been collaborating ever since.
You have to watch this.
(children cheering)
Hey, guys. Michael here.
And Ava.
Today, we are at Liberty Ministries thrift store
hoping to pick up some really cool, unique, fun pieces
that we're going to mix and match, refashion,
and hopefully come up with something really cool and fun.
Wish us luck, guys. Let's go.
(upbeat music)
We are so excited to create new looks
from the thrifted pieces that we found.
I was lucky enough to find a pair of Levi jeans for myself.
And I found this really amazing blanket.
I got a little sentimental.
I'm thinking of my grandmother
And for me, I have this cute denim shirt
which we will upcycle and put new cool details into it.
And I have pink curtains which I will upcycle
and make a new skirt.
All right, so we're gonna get started
sewing these pieces up and putting together
a cool daddy-daughter look for you, guys.
I am so proud of my dad.
He has all of these cool and unique ideas.
We can't wait for you guys to see what we created.
Hope you like it.
(audience clapping)
I love them.
Please welcome, Michael and Ava Gardner.
(audience clapping and cheering)
(upbeat music)
Okay.
Give me a high five.
You did an amazing job with that sweater.
Thank you.
I mean, you are really good at sewing.
(audience clapping)
And Ava, I'm so happy to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
Oh my goodness.
I have to just tell you I really admire you guys.
And why did you start doing this?
What was the idea and inspiration?
So, I always say God turned my pain into power.
I grew up without my father.
So, when I became a dad, I wanted to make sure
that she had all the things that I longed for
when I was a kid.
So, it just became the tool that I used to bond with her
and teach her about love, self confidence.
Much of what I struggle with growing up without my father.
I mean, she's literally my best friend.
Awww.
You know, she...
(audience clapping)
How do you feel about having a dad
who says something like that?
I love my dad and I really feel like
he understands how much I love him.
So, for him to say that makes me feel so good.
(laughs)
(audience clapping)
And you deserve that.
But why sewing? What gave you the idea for sewing?
So, what's interesting is my grandma actually sewed
for my mom and my aunts
when she was (clears throat) raising them.
My sister actually grabbed my mom's sewing machine
and started sewing and I just saw it and just was inspired.
And then, kind of watching Ava's personality.
She's kinda sassy and fun.
So, I just felt like maybe she would enjoy modeling.
So, I grabbed the machine, went thrifting,
started making her clothes
and I just put the phone up to her and she started posing
and here we are seven years later.
And Ava, what is this like for you?
You've got this awesome dad.
And he has this really fun idea
that's really unique and interesting.
What did you think?
Were you like, "I wanna be a model.
I wanna make clothes too."
Like, what's your side of the story?
I really love modeling.
I feel like it's a big part of me
and I never thought about doing it,
but when my dad started making clothes for me,
I just started to feel confident
and to feel loved and to feel inspired to model.
(audience clapping)
Well, we all love how connected you both are
and the amazing clothes that you create together.
So, when Drew Crew member and founder of Harlem Fashion Row,
Brandice Daniel heard your story, she had a message for you.
Watch this. She's amazing.
Hi, Michael and Ava.
I love what you two are doing so much
and wanna help you continue to succeed.
I wanna personally mentor you both as well as invite you
to our next Harlem's Fashion Row's Fashion Summit.
There you'll be able to chat with fellow emerging designers
and hear from some of the biggest names in fashion.
I'd also love to promote you two on our Instagram page.
You are both so inspiring
and I cannot wait to work with you more.
Wow.
(audience applauding)
(speaker drowned out by clapping)
It was.
(laughs)
Brandice is amazing.
Wow. Thank you so much.
Wait until you get with her.
She wants to mentor you and introduce you to people.
Wow. Thank you.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
Well, thank you, Michael and Ava Gardner
for being who you are.
Thank you.
Being the epitome of what good dad program
really wants to be.
And I just really am happy to hang out with you guys today.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)